well at least 18 people have been killed
and fighting between Sudan's warring
sides at a market in the capital
Khartoum the violence came after the
Army reportedly pulled out of talks with
the paramilitary rapid support forces
both sides accuse each other of
violating a truce that was meant to
allow the safe passage of humanitarian
Aid meanwhile the United States has
imposed sanctions targeting four
companies linked to Sudan's Army and the
rsf the measures are aimed at putting
pressure on both parties to stop the
conflict well let's bring in our
correspondent hibber Morgan she joins us
now from onderman Hibbert it's clear
that the fighting is continuing despite
all these ostensible truces
yes indeed now Thursday was a day of
intense artillery strikes in parts of
the capital Khartoum there's been
artillery strikes from the city of
andhurman towards the northern part of
the capital in the city of bahri where
there is a lot of rsf presence there's
also been artillery strikes in the
southern part of the capital the
Sudanese Army has been trying since the
early hours of Thursday morning to try
to take over a camp known as labor which
is uh one of the camps of the rapid
support forces and which is something
that the Army has been trying to gain
control of for the past few days but it
looks like it has started its offensive
on Thursday this of course comes off the
back of an artillery strike in the
southern part of the capital as well
that left 18 people killed in a
Marketplace in a city in the district of
mayo in the southern part of the capital
now hospital staff say that over 100
people were also injured in that
artillery strike and that they're facing
a shortage of medical personnel and
blood to be donated to those who've been
injured as a result of the strikes
residents there blame both the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army
saying that it's the result of their war
that civilians have been caught up in
the middle they say that there's no
presence of any military force there
whether it's the rsf or the Rapid or the
Sudanese Army and that the shellings is
now targeting civilians and affecting
civilians who are caught up in the
conflicts between the two sides yeah but
as all of that fighting continues there
are multiple tracks of negotiations at
the moment to try to end it I see the
U.S is trying to put the pressure on and
Jeddah is that likely to go anywhere
well for the time being the Army
announced that it is suspending and it's
worth noting it's a suspension and not a
withdrawal from the indirect talks
between the Army and the rapid support
forces which are being mediated by Saudi
Arabia and the United States now the
United States on Thursday also imposed
sanctions on Army entities and entities
belonging to the rapid support forces uh
parts of them being based here in hartum
and one of them based in the United Arab
Emirates you have Al Junaid which is one
of the companies that belongs to the
rapid support forces and tradiv another
company that belongs to the rapid
support forces but is based in the UAE
and then you have the defense industrial
system that's the that's the industrial
system that is responsible for procuring
equipments and ammunition and cars and
vehicles for the Sudanese Army as well
as the uh Jihad company here in the
capital hartsuman in Sudan which is also
part of the defense industrial system
now the US says the reason why it's
imposing sanctions is to limit the
military capabilities of the those two
sites to force them into the negotiation
table both both sides are currently
present in Jeddah and it's not clear if
there will be talks uh again between
them after the Army suspension of talks
now the U.S says that it feels like the
both sides are not serious with regards
to the ceasefire that has been
repeatedly violated but for the time
being it looks like uh there are no
talks happening and pressure is being
put on both sides to resume talks to for
at least a temporary ceasefire from
humanitarian Aid to come into those in
need in the capital and other parts of
the country well we'll see how that goes
Heber Morgan there for us in onderman in
Sudan thank you hema